so first here obviously within the realm
of this movie andy would have gotten the
buzz lightyear toy because he loves
lightyear the movie so much i'm
wondering for both of you do you
remember the very first movie you saw
that you loved so much that you had to
run out and buy the toys ah has no one
asked you that that's a great question
and no no one has asked me i was sure
that was gonna be one that i was gonna
you know have to repeat to you you know
man
i'm trying to you have
the gem of it all like the gem and the
holograms i loved that show and i have
to imagine because i remember getting it
for christmas and it came with like a
cassette and i have to imagine because i
was so obsessed with the show my pa i
must have been yeah that's why they gave
it to me for christmas i'm sure for me
it was always disney channel like
anything disney channel that you know
that's so raven liz mcguire [ __ ]
perfect any of the d
uh you know what is a cheetah girls so
it's like any of those shows i wanted
any of the merch that they had to assist
with it you know disney's had me in a
chokehold for years
oh all totally makes sense i mean i'm
gonna go out and buy a million socks
toys
you know what if they made human
resources toys i would go roman
resources come on rochelle
i love that you love that [ __ ] the show
is like exceptional
yeah back to light year another uh
question here inspired by the actual
story one of my favorite parts of the
movie is when buzz recalls going through
training and he's not very good in
training but alicia is the one who sees
something special in him and encourages
him to become the space ranger he
becomes so for both of you starting out
in your acting careers who was your
alicia someone who saw something in you
during your toughest times and put you
on the path and brought you to where you
are today oh
i mean i think definitely my one of my
teachers who changed my life the course
of my life was my junior uh creative
writing teacher in high school who
mismiles router sarah miley's writer hi
ms milan and um who
uh got me from thinking that i wanted to
be a lawyer into thinking about becoming
an artist it was some not something i
ever thought about but until she said it
and it's
part of why i'm sitting in this chair
now oh my god but i also could see you
as a mean lawyer
i know you would be like that's enough
my mom
my mom yes my mom for me my mom always
saw it for me she just always just
encouraged me and always encouraged me
even more specifically to do all of the
things you know to not feel like you
know she always said you could do like
judy garland you could do like sammy
davis jr you could be anything you want
to be you can do all the things and so
she's always encouraged me and it made
me think to infinity and beyond i could
do all the things doing all the things
for sure right now all right i'll wrap
up with this one because i was reading a
lot in the production notes how the
entire cast heavily influenced how their
characters turned out in the final film
so what's the biggest difference between
your character first script you read or
maybe even uh you know early concept art
and what we see in the finished film
here i don't know there's so much i
think she i think she got my is he got
refined but she was always there you
know she was always there um you know as
this curious um
i think
i guess maybe a little bit like
there was more development on her not
being totally perfect you know
the finding that rhythm between her
being everything a leader needs to be
and then her understanding that she was
that already without being the
stereotypical ideas of what a leader
needed to be
that that storyline became kept getting
more and more refined i love it
thank you guys so much for your time
today thank you
you